une conférence a remplacé le téléphone
rouge mais l'entretien du jour entre joe
biden est vladimir poutine a bien les
accents de guerre froide les deux hommes
échangent ce mardi autour de la
situation en ukraine le président des
états unis tout d'abord redoutent les
intentions de son homologue russe dont
des milliers de soldats manoeuvre à la
frontière ukrainienne mais également des
cyberattaques le président russe de son
côté souhaite notamment une garantie que
l'ukraine ne rejoindra pas l'otan prouve
la dîmière poutine ce sommet avec joe
biden est en tout cas déjà un progrès
une victoire diplomatique pour quoi on
voit cela avec julian calling à moscou
la presse russe hier et aujourd'hui on
se félicite en tout cas on signale que
ce nouveau rendez vous donc par
visioconférence est plutôt un bon signe
ça permet à moindre frais de garder le
contact ouvert un dialogue qui avaient
été ouverts bien sûr au mois de juin
avec donc cette rencontre à genève est
désormais par contre on sait pas
beaucoup d'illusions par contre à moscou
aujourd'hui sur les avancées concrètes
qu'on peut attendre de ce rendez vous
par exemple le porte parole de poutine
dimitri peskov a year déclaré qu' il ne
fallait pas s'attendre à des percées
aujourd'hui c'était simplement encore
une fois pour garder le contact et le
dialogue ouvert mais c'était difficile
également selon lui est bien de
reconstruire une relation vraiment
endommagés et ces derniers mois entre
donc l'occident on peut dire les états
unis surtout et la russie est donc bien
sûr le sujet principal aujourd'hui sera
sans doute l'ukraine car c'est au tour
de l'ukraine justement ce dossier très
important que la tension est encore
montée ces derniers jours vous lisiez
avec les troupes notamment russes qui
s'approche donc de la frontière
ukrainienne en russie